[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody happy sunday yeah sunday
we're back and uh neighbor across the
street happens to be mowing the lawn on
his damn right on lawn mowers
[Laughter]
so if you can hear something in the
background that's what it is these are
people across the street are blowing the
lawn we finally got around to doing
zardoz
i could have sworn we did zardoz before
like on a movie retrospective a long
time ago
because we watched it like a couple
years back i remember because i had
actually never seen the whole thing
straight through i had just seen like
parts of it yeah and i think that we i
think we watched [ __ ] case cinema about
it because it's like he loves that
[ __ ] movie and he even does like
jokes about it still even though he did
that review like eight years ago
uh so i was like yeah we really gotta
get around and watch zardoz gets a uh
gets us a reputation for being a crazy
ass [ __ ] movie it is kind of crazy
it's not as crazy as you think it is i
went back and we went back and we
watched it again last night
if you have the subtitles on
so you can read it it makes a lot more
sense all right because some of the
dialogue gets kind of lost in the
visuals
and they made a big
error
by opening the movie up
with like an introduction that has a got
a floating head talking to you
some dude and he's telling you that this
might happen
yeah like a highlighter i'm a god and
i'm like what the [ __ ] is good so that
kind of
that kind of disorients you from the
very beginning
i would re-edit this that movie without
that introduction and just allow people
to wonder what the [ __ ] is going on well
see i think that um actually if you guys
didn't know this was written directed
and produced by john borman
prior to this had done deliverance yeah
and after this did exorcist two the
heretics yes he did excalibur and he did
excalibur which i love excalibur yeah i
do too yeah good um but yeah so yeah so
he makes like really good [ __ ] and you
know some kind of questionable [ __ ]
because like i said exorcist two is not
so good
but uh i think that the i gotta see it
you've never seen exorcist two
it's awful but it's kind it's awful and
it's entertaining maybe it's better than
you think it is if you go back and watch
it i don't know because i just watched
it like a year or two ago i'm like yep
it still sucks but you know what i mean
it's i tried i did yeah um
this is actually a high quality movie
it's it's very intelligent and it's a
wild-ass story and everything in this
movie came true basically it's about
transhumanism
breakaway civilizations
population control
uh [ __ ] vengeance all that stuff is
in there
it's um it's very much a movie of its
time
during this time they're doing soylent
green
they're doing planet of the apes
they're doing apocalyptic type movies
that involve you know
world catastrophes and that's what this
is it's a world catastrophe
and
it's just the the way that this movie is
presented
it's a world catastrophe in a
psychedelic hippie england that's what
it's like
it's [ __ ] bizarre
what does make a lot of sense what i was
gonna say was that um the
what i was gonna say when i was saying
that it was john moorman was that he
actually as far as i uh could determine
he did not actually want that prequel
with the floating head good thing uh
that was just kind of like the studio
that added that because they thought
that it was and see well like when we
were watching that last night like one
it's super cheesy okay which you know
that makes it more entertaining but
it didn't really need to be there
because they introduced the concept of
that guy arthur frayne like who that is
like in the first 10 or 15 minutes of
the movie so it's like you don't really
need to
know that right out of the gate i think
it would have been better to just start
without that yeah and let people like
figure it out on their own i would
re-release sardos a director's cut and
[ __ ] cut that out of there
and that movie would be a lot better
without that in without it
what do you call it it's not only an
introduction it's um
what do you do when you have [ __ ]
somebody explaining [ __ ] it's like a
narration like an airplane narration
yeah you don't [ __ ] need it it
actually sucks the wind out of the movie
it's better it's better when it starts
right after that
as soon as that's over it's good
and it's just this [ __ ] weird ass
apocalyptic scene
these dudes running around and [ __ ]
orange shorts with [ __ ] bandoliers
little diapers angry heads and [ __ ]
you know
working this huge stone
gumdrop shaped [ __ ] i love that
bigfoot face of an angry god it looks so
good yeah it looks great looks great
comes out of the [ __ ] mist in the sky
and they're worshiping it and it goes
they're going zardas zardoz they're all
[ __ ] tripping it's coming like what
the [ __ ] they had like slaves with them
that were toiling the [ __ ] soil and
[ __ ]
and it comes down and it gets
the gun is good
the penis is evil and they're going yeah
yeah
the penis shoots seeds
and those seeds become man which pure
which
which destroys the earth the gun shoots
death and destroys man and purifies the
earth you know like and it's spitting
out all these damn guns
they're getting new guns and [ __ ]
yeah
yeah yeah
like wow and then the [ __ ] head takes
off and i mean that's quite an opening
yeah
what the [ __ ] and that's really how the
movie was supposed to start not this
[ __ ] floating funnyman head that it
was like wizard of oz [ __ ] which there
is it was the devil's references in this
and uh man i wish they'd cut that intro
out well you can just pretend it's not
it's not there
supposed to have a really strong start
like that
and then in that flying head [ __ ] out
of the [ __ ] grain a bunch of big pile
of gray because they put all the crop
yields inside the head
like [ __ ]
double 007 comes out of there shot
connor
sean connery's naked ass [ __ ] pops up
out of there and he's got a [ __ ]
webley 455 revolver and he's looking
around and they got people in plastic
bags and
[ __ ] supplies and [ __ ] and he sees a
dude little
wizard like little [ __ ] run down
and he's
and he's and he shoots him pow like that
and he goes i could have shown you i
could have shown you and a dude fell out
you know what what a waste and he falls
out of the mouth and the head [ __ ]
lance
in this place called the damn
and the vortex there's many vortexes the
vortex is like a little british
farm town you know people are out there
making bread and you know and but
hanging out yeah he finds his way into
there and [ __ ] horses with their
titties flopping about yeah no
[Laughter]
that's one does now the lead character
in this movie is this
uh you know sean connery's playing
playing this guy named zed he was the
one that killed the dude when he's up in
the damn
gumball head
called the gumball god head
and uh
he's real intelligent he gets there and
figures out how to [ __ ]
use a personal computer and [ __ ]
can see that certain things are
holograms and
voice activated computers and it's just
weird they they
they recognize him as an outsider and
they know what he is he's an executioner
and it turns out
all these people that live in this
vortex or immortals that they don't die
if their bodies are destroyed they just
re they just respawn and re-hatch
in the center of a town in this big uh
what they call a tabernacle i think
that's what they called it
and um everybody's in there they're all
equal and they're all intelligent um
and they're all [ __ ] hippie-ish and
[ __ ] kind of
pansexual looking or
genderless kinda in a way
but um he finds out that they've
because they're they're 200 something
years old
they don't have sex they don't [ __ ]
because they don't need to they don't
need to reproduce anymore because they
don't die yeah they don't reproduce they
don't have sex they don't they don't
sleep they don't really don't sleep they
don't really do much anything and
they're getting
they get so bored they'll become
kind of uh
[ __ ] they just stand around and do
nothing what do they call them the uh
yeah there are some that are that have
uh gotten so bored with existence that
now they're called the apathetic the
apathetics so they just like kind of
stand around in a barn and just like
like
stand there the apathetics then some of
them uh start to [ __ ] try to rock the
boat and bunk the system and call
[ __ ] on the way things are being run
so they punish them by aging them they
don't kill them but they just age them
and they can age them so much to where
they just become senile and they put
them off in these in this [ __ ] old
folks home where they're dressed up in
[ __ ] tuxedos and [ __ ] like they're in
a nightclub they don't they can't really
remember a whole lot yes they're just
like dancing yeah what were they called
the renegades the renegades that's right
so
zed realizes that uh
because you know he makes a friend in
there called friend he makes
he makes a friend in there called friend
and friend tells him that uh that you
know yeah the dude that you killed in
the [ __ ] zardoz head was a friend of
mine and he's you he's been um doing
he's been running the outside world for
us the past 200 something years and we
don't really know you know you know we
don't know what he was up to he's out
there [ __ ] just doing his own thing
each one of them has a job and they
don't have there's no government to
answer to so they just do whatever they
want to do
yeah mostly it looked like they just
kind of baked green loaves of bread yeah
they all had to be equal so to do that
they had to cook and cook their own food
yeah everybody had to do their own [ __ ]
they had to do their own chores yeah you
had to clean up after yourself you had
to cook for yourself yeah unless they
were apathetic they just stood stood
there and they just pile them up in the
barn and they'd feed them give them some
bread and then they just stand there
they were kind of like the mentally ill
but uh turns out
that um what was what was this zardos
guy's name
arthur frayne frain yeah fraid so it
turns out arthur frayne
was uh
selectively breeding people
the brutals that's what they call them
like out in the the brutals were the
regular people
well they were all called that like yeah
i guess they were all called brutal yeah
brutals right yeah um now some of the
brutals were uh were given the job of
executioner their job was to just go out
and just annihilate them
and they were just hunters and they
would just hunt down other humans and
kill them
and to to keep the earth's population
low
that way they wouldn't overpopulate and
threaten the vortex cities where you
know basically like basically it's like
google smart cities but they look like
they're green though they're green
energy they're carbon neutral i guess
you could say they don't have any
technology well they have technology but
it's all masked
uh it just looks real primitive well
they kind of i mean the tabernacle is
essentially like the internet yes it's a
super computer and they can talk into
their rings yeah which is kind of weird
it's kind of like a smartphone actually
and you can just like ask it questions
and like it'll tell you [ __ ] you know
what i mean so
the vortexes
are keeping the external population of
brutals down they're keeping them low so
they don't
so the populations don't get big enough
to
to threaten them you find out later that
how the vortex started they were rich
people
rich people and smart people
and business people
the earth started to overpopulate it
started to die off so they built these
basically smart cities is what they were
and hooked them together with the
internet
and then um
uh they had a shield wall around them
that people couldn't penetrate
and then um
they released these
people uh these executioners to go out
there and kill them
kill the humans
kill humans like [ __ ] planet of the
apes
well zed was one of them zed had a bunch
of friends all his friends were
executioners
well
arthur was selectively breeding them by
command
so they were getting smarter and smarter
as they were going along they were
becoming kind of like a new species
kind of like a noble savages is what
what you'd call them in literature today
where they were barbaric but they were
real intelligent
um
well
because the vortexes started to fail
and so many of them were going renegade
and some of them were coming apathetic
there weren't enough of them that were
active
there weren't enough active ones to grow
food inside the vortexes
so they told all the damn
executioners
to stop killing people and start
capturing them enslaving them and making
them grow crops
and the executioners weren't real happy
about that but we want to kill people
right
well they were they felt that they had
been betrayed by zardoz
their god had [ __ ] changed his plan
so
you find out later that zed
learned how to read somebody encouraged
him to learn how to read in a library he
never saw the guy
well they tell you who they tell you it
is later yeah he learned to read and
while he was reading in the library he
re he remember he was learned how the
world used to be and how the vortexes
came about and the human depopulation
plan how that came about
so he and the other executioners hatched
this plan
for zed to stow away inside the [ __ ]
zardos head to go back to wherever it
came from and he was going to signal
them and tell them where it went and
drop the shield wall and let them in to
invade it and kill kill everybody for
revenge
but it didn't go that smoothly a bunch
of other [ __ ] happened it's a good movie
well the thing about it too is that the
eternals the people that lived in the
vortex they wanted to die turns out they
wanted to die because they were sick
because they were sick of being immortal
and they're just like you know they just
wanted something to happen so it's just
kind of like when the so when they got
invaded at the end they were just like
yay yeah please kill us yeah but that
didn't that didn't really help zed
because the the vortex super computer
wouldn't allow that to happen yeah
because it was it was designed to
protect the people at all costs it was
coddling them
yeah that was it that was uh kind of
written into the programming like when
they first started yeah this is uh the
movie is actually set in the year 2293
yeah actually now it was a pretty
ambitious story
yeah it was real
well done actually
with the the budgets and the technology
at the time
the only thing that
is really wrong with this film is that
beginning intro and then the scene where
he goes into the computer crystal it's
run by the it goes into their version of
the internet
and
he has to defeat the super computer from
within it somehow
because of the technology of the time
they really couldn't it just ended up
being like a trippy head trip him in
like a fun house with a bunch of damn
mirrors areas of people going seeing
himself yeah
[ __ ] he's shooting at stuff over the
70s somehow he kills an image of himself
in there and that somehow it's not
really explained somehow that short
circuits the computer which allows uh
zed to come out and deactivate the
shield wall and all his buddies run in
and start [ __ ] killing everybody you
know and they're going to kill me kill
me and they're [ __ ] i want to die and
it's kind of cheesy and they're laughing
about it laughing about dying
um
and a bunch of other stuff happens
the
edit and then it's it's the the edit of
the
of the final scenes is kind of
um uneven
yeah it gets a little messy towards that
messy
it
modern technology in a tighter edit i
think would clean that up
and then in the end it had a weird
sequence where
zed and the and the former high
priestess of the tabernacle i guess she
was like a high priest this is probably
what you would call her
they escaped together and had a son and
then the son leaves they're living in a
cave and it shows like fast motion and
then they grow old and die they're two
skeletons sitting there it's just a yeah
they're saying that it's gone back to
like the quote unquote natural it went
back to the nap because the the the um
the whole
the whole moral of the story the whole
lesson was is that
transhumanism and breakaway
civilizations and people trying to live
forever and
people separating themselves into master
classes and slave classes and [ __ ] that
it's it's not natural that it's not
sustainable and they're trying to be all
ecologically conscious
but they kind of twisted it into a knot
that's not the way ecology is people
supposed to live
have children and die
and mankind maybe is supposed to die out
if it has to it's not it's not normal to
stop that process that's what it meant
um but it's a good movie
it's weird because i kind of feel like
when this came out
this amazed me i didn't even realize so
john borman he had just made deliverance
right which was a massive massive hit
so the studios were basically after that
they were like carte blanche you can
make whatever you want yeah uh however
when he came at them with this script
which he had written uh what ended up
happening was that he actually wanted to
do um a lord of the rings thing he
wanted to do an adaptation of lord of
the rings yeah so he came to the studio
and said i want to do an adaptation of
lord of the rings and they're like yeah
no that's gonna cost like 50 bajillion
dollars no so um so he's like okay well
i guess i'll just write a new story like
in a weird world it wasn't supposed to
be initially like super far in the
future um but he was kind of more
interested in doing like sci-fi but not
you know and post-apocalyptic but more
kind of philosophical i guess if you
want to go that way like i said just
what would happen if people act actually
did
live forever like would they actually
just get sick of it after a while so he
wanted to sort of like explore those
kind of things
now interestingly sean connery was not
uh the first choice
it was supposed to be burt reynolds
uh because burt reynolds had just been
in deliverance yeah so he had just
worked with him so he wanted him to be
in it that'd have been good actually but
then burt reynolds got sick like he had
some kind of illness and uh so he
couldn't do it so they got sean connery
because sean connery i guess he had just
done
uh diamonds or forever like he had just
stopped doing like the bond movies and
he hadn't really been getting much work
uh after that burt reynolds would have
been better in this role
now yeah now i understand why sean
connery had a burt reynolds mustache
yeah that's right it's like well can we
can we make him look like burt reynolds
so he puts that big [ __ ] smokey in
the bandit stash on him
sean connery was it was taller than burt
reynolds but burt reynolds had a kind of
a better build he was about yeah because
that's what he wanted um somebody that
was kind of like you know
just stocky yeah like kind of a big yeah
i think burt reynolds would have like
looked a lot better whereas sean connery
is like was was in good shape but he's
like more tall and he's like leaner yeah
you know where burt reynolds was like
kind of more bigger like muscular bert
would have been better
well he couldn't do it that's why but he
was actually the first choice bird's
[ __ ] cockiness would have come
through
that's true
because honestly zed in this the
character doesn't really have a lot of
lines no he's kind of like supposed to
be the strong silent type i guess yeah
and you can tell he's uh very he still
kind of come comes across if you ask me
just comes across as an englishman he's
just a little bit too civilized
reynolds kind of had that [ __ ]
swagger to him he kind of
reynolds could [ __ ] come off a little
bit better as a barbarian i think
especially around all those british
actors yeah because i guess he would be
the only one talking like an american
would have been funny if he'd been in
there like talking like smokey and the
bandit and he had like a southern accent
this movie
could be remade
and it would be badass with today's
technology if it was done right
yeah
another thing is that i was amazed to
discover that this movie only cost 1.5
million
and honestly like the cinematography and
the visuals in this are pretty awesome
like considering that it costs that it
was that cheap they're in there
mentioning logan's run i was saying the
same thing to jenny when we were
watching yeah it has a very logan's
running this is very much like a british
logan's run
sort of i mean it has a lot of
differences too yeah a lot of original
thinking but yeah it is that same
post-apocalyptic kind of
huxley style
you know what i mean yeah there's a lot
of these kind of movies yeah
they were
this was a time for those
there's a good movie yeah it's just it
just had
some flaws to it but it it does it does
have character it's got a lot of
character to it um
the
the costumes are kind of [ __ ] out
there they're very 70s
i really wouldn't
i really wouldn't address the
executioners that way to me they looked
those boots looks very store-bought to
me
very you know the [ __ ] 70s [ __ ]
sexy
[ __ ] high type boots they they were
like right out of [ __ ] i would
address them more kind of like kind of
like native americans you know buckskin
pants with
[ __ ] you know uh leather boots
leather
buckskin boots and just probably bare
chested or something
yeah which they mostly were honestly i
think it looked better because like i
said it would be good if you were going
to a convention
and if you could get some thigh-high
boots and a red kind of diaper speedo
situation and some red bandoliers and
then you get you'd have to have the mask
too because some of them had those masks
on that were like front and back like
janice yeah you know what i mean
uh you know where it had like a face on
either side and they looked like the
zardoz head but they were kind of red
yeah you know what i mean where whereas
the zardar's head was kind of like look
like a big stone head or plastic i
basically would have had them hooked up
like [ __ ] apache warriors with those
damn masks and m16s and stuff which some
of those guys did have m16s yeah that
would have been really cool i mean the
70s was kind of like a fashion tragic
decade largely
so it's like
you know you're not gonna uh yeah
somebody uh oracle said about uh
charlotte rampling being great in this
and she is and it's really weird and
somebody mentioned orca too and we
actually watched orca before this yeah
and i had forgotten that charlotte
rampling was also an orca so i was like
oh my god we had an accidental charlotte
rambling double feature orca was a good
movie we'll probably talk about that one
tomorrow because i had just been wanting
to watch it because i remember watching
it a bunch of times when i grew up and i
was like man i need to see that again
but then tom's like let's watch zardoz
and i was like okay now the thing about
it i think the first time i saw it we
watched zardoz a couple years back
probably like three years ago two years
something like that and i remember being
like wow that was weird as [ __ ] um and i
kinda and i mostly like followed it and
everything
but this time watching it i guess
because i had gotten over
man this is so [ __ ] weird
and i was actually following all the
dialogue and like you said we had the
closed captioning on which always helps
because my hearing is bad so it's always
kind of like it also helps to keep track
of exactly what was said because you
read it and yeah you read it and heard
it you read it and heard it so i i mean
i always like to have closed captioning
on even if i you know in a quiet room
because it's just in case i miss
something or somebody mumbles
so uh so having that on really helped me
follow this stuff and i was like really
for the first two thirds of the movie i
was kind of like wow this actually isn't
really confusing no because i kind of
had the impression the first time i
watched it that it was kind of like
confusing that's cause that intro yeah
whiplash of that intro
it's not confusing though i mean like
the last part of it goes a little
doolally where he's kind of like oh
that's a crystal and now i'm inside it
and suddenly i i didn't get that that
was it i mean i got it but i didn't get
why him doing that one thing like made
no like broke it i don't know
that doesn't make any sense well it
it was whatever technology kinda yeah
each person in the vortex and all the
other vortexes had a crystal implanted
into their head yeah which allowed the
computer to
um
allowed them to be able to communicate
with the super computer and it stored
all their thoughts and memories so that
when they responded or see when they
respond
in the in the damn
into the end of the baby into the rebat
into the into the rebooting baby batch
they would have the memories of the
former life
um
somehow he was able to get inside that
crystal
didn't really explain how when he woke
up he was still in his hands so i guess
he went into it mentally
and he somehow defeated it but it
doesn't quite explain it it was kind of
like what whatever technology yeah i
didn't really get like why
i didn't get like the symbolism of him
like shooting himself
inside the crystal and then that
destroyed the crystals on him yeah it
didn't it was
it it pro maybe it made sense if you
read a book
about it but but this wasn't even from a
book this is an original story okay it's
like i said the director also wrote the
story it was whatever technology yeah
they they just had to get it done
somehow so and
the budgetary constraints and the
technology of the time
and the understandings of computers and
technology of the time wasn't very good
they just kind of made things up yeah
the idea of implants and internet
internets and thought and and
thought activated stuff is not far off
that's what i'm saying so i was going to
say that probably back in the 70s this
would have seemed like a lot weirder
yeah because they didn't really have
anything that was sort of like a real
world
internet you know like yeah they didn't
have that so it's like nowadays people
like oh like a crystal implant and like
you know they're all like uh you know
hooked up to the internet they're
uploading their memories right like that
most people get that
to get that concept now so it's not that
strange yeah it was more it was mostly
just little things that i did yeah the
idea of uploading your consciousness
into into a into a machine you know
they're already trying to figure out how
to do that so
it's within possibility
and then the whole idea of
rich people in a breakaway civilization
just defense trying to protect
themselves from
a world of starving mass and masses of
people who are destroying ecology
that's
something understandable now that you
think that maybe they could do that or
that they are doing that controlling
population
uh by various means you know imploding
exploding economies and starting wars
and releasing diseases and weird [ __ ]
you know that they do
that's what this is talking about
and uh
[ __ ] zed does commentary on that at
the end
he ends up being a superman he ends up
knowing everything they know
everything the computer knew too
didn't he
he ended up basically yeah well they
said well because they taught him
everything that was in the crystal like
when he went in there right because the
crystal was like penetrate me and i was
just like oh okay he had all the old
world knowledge that he had when he was
in the
the libraries
all that old world savagery from [ __ ]
killing all those people and knew he
knew the human cost of things and then
he knew all their high-tech stuff and
all their new age stuff
so they were getting back to kind of the
old school concept of the noble savage a
dude who
has the power of creation and
destruction he has yeah he's getting
back to the balance of this and that
it's balance yeah it's all about balance
yeah because he had all the things he
was like he had you know been trained as
a savage but he also
was genetically engineered and he was
like civilized as well yeah he was also
learning faster than them because he had
been genetically or
not like genetically engineered but
selectively bred yeah to be more
intelligent faster and stronger even
though he wasn't educated it didn't
matter i mean he was learning things
just on his own well i think there was a
kind of a throwaway line in there that
said that he remembered everything that
he heard yeah like he had you know like
photographic memory essentially like
that yeah i think like i said it was
just like one line but i wasn't i'm
pretty sure it was in there well that
guy tested him and started throwing out
lines from um
classic literature yeah like t-s-l-e-t-s
which i i kind of feel like a lot
this movie is kind of um
you know it's so it does kind of go in
this philosophical uh kind of
high-minded literature kind of thing so
it does have you know i i think at the
time people criticized it for being kind
of like pretentious or being like over
over-ambitious for the budget and stuff
um you know but it really does have a
lot of
i don't know i i kind of feel like maybe
it is a little overindulgent but that's
okay
honestly it doesn't really bother me all
that much and it's just like so weird
that it's like really entertaining to
watch yeah so i'm not bothered by it i
kind of like that
it did really badly um you know
obviously in uh you know in the original
you know when it was originally released
in 1974 and it got like terrible reviews
other than a few like there were a few
good reviews that said you know maybe
people just don't get it or whatever um
but obviously it's kind of gotten a
reputation as a cult classic over the
years
just because you can i mean you can just
drop acid and watch this because it's
just weird as [ __ ]
but there is actually a story in there
and there is actually interesting ideas
in there yeah um so it's not just like
weird for the sake of weirdness no it's
it's very intelligent the movie's very
intelligent
it's very ambitious
it's overreaching a lot
they don't quite have
the budget and the technology to really
pull this off but they come close
yeah yeah it it needed better special
effects in a couple scenes like i said
the crystal scene
and there needed to be a better
explanation of what had happened in
there
some of the edit needed to be tightened
up
that intro needs to [ __ ] go
yeah it's not necessary they don't need
it yeah i understand this movie was
ahead of its time
so they were afraid of [ __ ]
of the audi they were underestimating
the audience like the audience will
never understand this we have to have
this
they made it worse by it by putting that
on there
because it was kind of goofy it's goofy
as [ __ ] but what kind of movies this is
a comedy what the hell you know what i
mean and then this real strong intro
with the head coming in
should have started with that
big powerful [ __ ] scene of that damn
head coming out of the sky and people
worshiping this thing
that was would have been mind-blowing in
the time that this came out
well what
and like i said only in the first 10 or
15 minutes you get the big head coming
you understand okay well this is a god
of whatever these people are yeah and
then so sean connery like stows away in
the head
and then they introduce arthur frane
who's the same guy that was like in the
first 10 minutes and i was like you
didn't even need that you didn't need
that [ __ ] i mean and it was like a lot
more mysterious because him coming out
of the head and then being like i could
have showed you i could have done this
yeah that was
that so he knew who he was and like the
guy that just like and then sean connery
just shoots him and i'm just kind of
like see that would like set up mystery
what if you if you kind of like come in
the beginning where he's basically
saying i'm a fake god
um you're kind of like blowing your load
yeah too i mean plus it's kind of goofy
so i just yeah i didn't think it was
there were really only two mistakes in
the movie if you ask me even for the
time
the intro
and the executioner's outfits
back in the 70s they could have done a
[ __ ] badass
mad max looking
executioner outfits or you could have
gone to stock
indian costumes from [ __ ] hollywood
[ __ ]
and dressed those up dyed them black or
something and put them in and that would
have made a great costume with that same
mask and everything those guns that have
been great because those masks were
kick-ass would kick ass yeah and that
would be like wow you know and that
would have i think the red [ __ ] it's
almost his outfit almost looks like the
[ __ ] red outfit from vampirella
remember the vampirina
they
but
had they changed those those two little
things that this movie i think would
have caught on a lot
faster would it have been a hit no
but it had been taken yeah it's too
weird it's too weird it was it was too
too far ahead of its time in the the
concepts
um
i mean seriously well maybe logan's run
was ahead of its time this was even more
even more out there than logan's run
but they got this [ __ ] off of reading
that same kind of literature that you
know logan's run and um you know [ __ ]
silent green and
planet of the apes it's coming from that
type of literature
even though there was no book before but
there he was reading something about
transhumanism and
breakaway civilizations and population
control and this is
you know a direct result of reading
those books i can tell
oracle says they were swinging for the
fences with zardoz even if they failed
they tried to be different yeah yeah see
that's what i'm saying if if you're
gonna if the movie's gonna quote unquote
fail in the sense of being a commercial
failure at least like try to make what
you wanna make even if it's [ __ ]
weird you know what i mean so in that
sense
he pretty much made what he wanted and
even though it took like a really long
time
i think i was looking at the wikipedia
page and uh bbc four actually called
this john borman's best movie
[Laughter]
excalibur was well i think deliverance
is the best baby but excalibur's up
there too i really we did review
excalibur i know we did i think
excalibur out excalibur
excalibur it's like a masterpiece
um that's just like you might that's
just like reading [ __ ] lamort to
harter you know you might as well just
read that but this is like
it's it's you take that
classic british mythology and you almost
just make it a damn [ __ ] religion
it's almost like a religious movie
watching excalibur
this kind you know what zardoz kind of
has a little bit of arthurian kind of
[ __ ] to it too yeah it feels mythic yeah
and you know i could i sit here and bag
on it on is the executioner costume you
look like a vampirella had that had they
just changed the color to black it would
have looked a lot better
yeah maybe they thought that the reds
stood out more they were trying to be
sci-fi yeah
like like it's they're trying to make it
look like the future
yeah
when
uh you know no the future didn't look
like that no that's not futuristic
you know
a futuristic a futuristic savage
they didn't know what the future was
going to look like in this year
they thought we were going to be wearing
all kind of crazy [ __ ] yeah directly in
the 2000s
you know if you say well he's got to be
a futuristic savage then that's the kind
of [ __ ] that that's like some
[ __ ] star trek television
program
exactly off like that
yeah this is yeah it's kind of like it's
kind of like star trek kind of went into
some of this kind of [ __ ] yeah
yeah
but yeah i'm gonna say like i said for
only one and a half million dollars um
this movie looks pretty [ __ ] cool i
mean it probably helps that
they shot most of it in ireland yeah um
some of the same locations that they
used for excalibur actually
but
um i was reading that they were having
trouble
because they shot in ireland and i guess
so like a lot of the actresses didn't
want to you know put have their boobies
hanging out because that was kind of
like you know but you know there because
there's a lot of boobies in there
there's a lot of nakedness and i was
like skinny girls mostly though yeah i
was like particularly like laughing at
the one scene where they're trying to
because like i said they don't have to
have sex anymore because they don't you
know they don't reproduce yeah they're
all kind of asexual yeah so they're just
kind of like fascinated by it like what
you know so they're trying to like what
makes basically what gives a dude an
erection yeah so they're like showing
him like some porn and he's just like
looking at it and not yeah you know
his [ __ ]
and everybody's like looking at it going
oh well look at that
you see when connery did that and to me
it was kind of corny
if it had been bert reynolds it made a
lot more sense
that [ __ ] dog yeah
because he'd be sitting there [ __ ]
chewing gumbo yeah
and it's just funny the way they're all
just standing around looking at us like
looking at him getting it right he's too
dignified to [ __ ] go yeah
that is a funny [ __ ] scene though i
just i mean i like the whole lead-up to
it because i love that charlotte
rampling is like kind of giving a sort
of like lecture
with the with the little cartoon penis
like you know getting an erection yeah
oh my god yeah this is a weird ass movie
you guys but it's
the more times you why i guess this is
true of any movie but the more times you
watch it like the less weird it seems
like the more sense it seems to make it
does like i said it does make sense it
does have a story it would have it would
have it would have not has made as much
sense to the general public back then
yeah it makes more sense now it makes a
lot more sense the concepts that they
were talking about
in this movie were decades ahead
of what you would see in a movie
population control and [ __ ] well not
really like i said
they kind of had that with soylent green
yeah um
but just
having the
those topics portrayed in this way
uh was ahead of [ __ ] its time you
know
that you have guys out there actively
hunting people down
and killing them to get a high score
back at the vortex and they they're
worshiping it as a god
but that's kind of how you would do it
oh uh fun fact that one scene where uh
sean connery shoots that one guy in the
head that's you know
that's cultivating the yeah whatever
real [ __ ] that was um that was john
borman that was the director okay that
was that was his cameo that was like i
want sean connery to shoot me in the
head
smoke hit him in the head and blew it up
and says man that was a good that was
that blank shot [ __ ] yeah that was
that was a good effect actually but i
didn't even realize but yeah that's john
borman so i thought that was kind of
funny that he went out to be his cameo
yeah and they show kind of like a
flashback to the apocalypse when
all these [ __ ] people were
banging on the outer shield wall trying
to get into the vortex and they're
screaming and they look all starving and
everything and that one woman
weird-looking woman who's screaming and
crying is the same one out of excalibur
who was screaming and crying when the
whole [ __ ] it's a screaming and
crying lady don't you remember that
when when uh when lancelot became the
[ __ ] um the cult leader who was just
walking the earth [ __ ] saying give up
it's it's the end is near remember that
and everybody's back they were wailing
and everything did you remember that
scene yeah that's sort of yeah it's that
same woman in there she's got the weird
ass looking teeth and that real long
head
he must know that woman he's like yeah
as weird as you look but we're gonna put
you back in this [ __ ] booty again she
looks like she's just starving to death
yeah that's that's funny if that's as an
actor that's kind of your yeah your
whole resume it's the screaming crime
i'm the screaming starving woman starved
to death but she's just she's
like you look at her imdb page and it's
all like starving woman starving women
starving
her skulls real long
occasionally wicked witch
real long teeth and lots of gums yeah
you know she looks like her [ __ ]
and she looks she looks insane but she's
in this movie too
but uh no i liked it good movie
uh oracle said something uh maybe
something like the warriors gang outfits
and the warriors yeah
yeah that's a pretty good word yeah
john gorra says there's an unwatchable
vamparella movie from the early 90s was
there
wait was pam anderson in that
god i hope so
i gotta have that she'd make it awesome
vampirella she could feel that roger
daltrey is in it
she could fill that costume out well now
i'm kind of curious yeah i mean i know
she was in barbed wire so i don't know
if i'm confusing those two things she
couldn't act
well no you know but she had big titties
she had dictated she was pretty she had
a good personality she was funny
that [ __ ] they accidentally leaked
leaked that damn porn or heard [ __ ]
tommy lee on that damn boat i mean you
know back in the day it's like yeah they
were the ones that broke that they're
the ones that first started that listen
accidentally released this fight
how'd that get out there how did our
homemade porn get out there they [ __ ]
oh my gosh now i have all this publicity
yeah what to do about it
it's pretty clever when you think about
it
man tommy lee was [ __ ] huge
god damn i don't even remember watching
that did it feel like a [ __ ] donkey
yikes yeah
[Laughter]
he was no joke
okay pat hatfield said i just got here
but i'm assuming you already mentioned
that this was originally supposed to
star burt reynolds yes yeah yeah yeah it
needed burt reynolds i mean
we got what we got he did a good job but
burt reynolds it makes a lot more sense
it would have made a lot more sense with
burt reynolds in it
now i'm kind of wondering if sean
connery just happened to have that same
mustache because you know 70s or if they
told him why don't you grow a big ass
mustache like bart
no but it makes more sense that have
been bert reynolds he would made that
little stocky kind of savage and [ __ ]
swagger and [ __ ] to him he was not as
burt reynolds was kind of dignified if
he asked me
he's he doesn't come across as a you
mean sean potter excuse me yeah uh sean
cotter sean connery's kind of [ __ ]
well because he was james bond yeah he's
a little too dignified for this role
um he doesn't come across as savage but
[ __ ] but burt reynolds good yeah he
can do that
yeah it might i can see that it might
have worked better with somebody that
was a little bit more of a bruiser yeah
yeah
you know somebody who didn't take [ __ ]
seriously and just had some strut
that's right
that's right
yeah right yeah
i don't know i don't think he'd like
that costume though that caught those
costumes were a big mistake well tayden
burt reynolds did bur dinner burt
reynolds posed nude in play girl or yeah
something yeah they did play girl yeah i
thought he did and it's i mean i
remember hearing that was the only issue
probably well to straight women anyway
probably
thank you camp guy
ot guy here didn't see the movie so i
just spew okay that's fine you haven't
seen zardoz
oh you guys do that one um yeah get some
uh get some drugs
and
get some drugs and watch this movie
it's uh it's pretty crazy it's pretty
weird yeah but if you just got here we
said that the movie does make sense you
just um
ignore the intro in the beginning and
just [ __ ] watch yeah because it's got
tacked on which kind of [ __ ] it up
just [ __ ] watch the dab movie
and pay attention to it have the
subtitles on see it's easier to keep
track of what's happening it makes
perfect sense
and it's a lot of good ideas in it it's
like up there with logan's run
crazier than logan's run more ambitious
oh big time a lot more ambitious than
logan's run time more of a mind [ __ ]
but the technologies they're talking
about and the concepts that they were
talking about were decades ahead it's
like what you talk about now
yes internets
[ __ ] implants
downloading [ __ ] consciousnesses into
a computer and then putting it into a
clone so you can come back to life
um
transhumanism
uh genetic engineering selective
breeding
[ __ ] population control uh kind of
like a controlled collapse of
civilization breakaway civilizations
then the breakaway civilization evolves
into a new species that uses the
original
[ __ ]
civilization as basically slaves but
they're not happy in the breakaway
civilization because it's not
naturalistic
you know their lust for life is gone it
it's good mood
pat asked is this movie based on a book
or series of books no this is actually
an original story by uh john borman the
director
as i mentioned who also did deliverance
and excalibur yeah and exorcist too
sorry
he made another access this too now
we can watch it if you want you said it
sucks huh okay
i mean
yeah you probably should see it i feel
like you should see it
you probably like it because you always
seem to like
you know you seem to like movies that
everyone else thinks are terrible but um
i kind of
uh yeah i just i remember i saw it a
couple years back so i was going to give
it another chance because i was like
well maybe it's not as bad as i remember
and i was like
yeah it's kind of as bad as i remember
uh exorcist 3 is awesome but
exorcist two
uh
i don't know i can't really think of any
person that because you know there's
always that one person that's like no
matter how shitty the movie is and how
much everybody hates it there's always
gonna be that one person that defends it
i mean i'm sure there's one out there
i've just never seen one
so but you should see it just for
cultural edification you know what i'm
saying because you've seen the first one
and you've seen the third one both of
which are awesome
second one not so much so
you you know what you probably dig it
because it has to do with like [ __ ]
uh
linda blair is in it yeah and she goes
to like some kind of parapsychology kind
of clinic
i'll see we'll see it so maybe we can
watch that later no i can recommend
zardoz it's worth writing
it's not a perfect movie it's got
problems it didn't have to do with the
director though they made him they made
him put that damn intro in the beginning
without that intro to just been a strong
movie through the whole thing it's got a
weird edit at the end it starts to get a
little bit ponderous
um
this could be re-edited
a [ __ ] really good director's cut of
this would i think would be great what
if they're ever going to remake this
really you know even with a like i said
even with the movie as as given i would
just re-edit get rid of that [ __ ]
intro and the only thing i would change
is just
the costumes on this executioners i'd
have more look like something out of
out of mad max or
apaches or something like that with
those damn [ __ ] masks on i love the
masks yeah those masks are mostly just
the boots and the [ __ ] little
red diapers that i was like what's that
that's a weird they kind of look like
some kind of weird persian or indian
[ __ ] shorts
what they look like like something that
you would go bathe in the gandhi's with
that the
well they kind of look like speedos yeah
they're slightly larger than snow yeah
they had pleats and [ __ ] on them
down the gandy's river you know some
[ __ ] yeah
something that a fake here would have on
[ __ ] doing a flute with the [ __ ]
cobra coming up climbing up the ropes
yeah something like that camp guy said i
have subtitles on for everything i watch
yeah i do too nowadays because otherwise
i mean like i said my my hearing's not
great i can hear people talking but
sometimes it just sounds like rubber so
it's nice to like
not
miss anything so i actually put it on
for everything uh i could remake this
[ __ ]
yeah i mean honestly
it probably should be at some pace stage
and i wouldn't change much
no i don't think i don't think much
needs to be changed about it it would be
very very minor changes yeah a lot of
just be special effects cool scg the
flying heads certain things that happen
a couple of things about the dialogue
that trick up the technology a little
bit some of the stuff didn't really
i mean i love the look of the flying
head i think you should leave that the
same because that's exactly that's
really kick-ass change anything with
that maybe have something with like
lasers coming out of its eyes to make it
look more impressive you know what i
mean i think that the face is like kind
of scary i think
yeah you know what i mean it's just i
mean that i would like [ __ ] [ __ ] a
brick if that's a big [ __ ] giant i
would make the head say some more things
because you know it does say some things
but i would make it say a little bit
more
[ __ ] you know
yeah the gun
is
the penis the gun is good
the penis is evil
the penis shoots seeds
that create men pew pew pew putrefy the
earth
the gun shoots death
[Laughter]
john gore says linda blair was super
cute in exorcist 2 terrible movie but
yeah she was actually really cute in
that uh louis says probably the worst
sequel to a classic movie the exorcist 2
is a train wreck yeah i agree
but uh like i said tom should probably
see it linda blair probably missed a
[ __ ] good career opportunity in porn
actually i think she was in a lot of
kind of soft core yeah stuff she was in
a lot of those kind of like women in
prison movies
she was in a lot of tv movies kind of
dumb she i guess i'm just waiting she
was in hell night yeah that's the way
the way society was at the time you
couldn't do porn and keep your
reputation in text uh yeah nowadays
nobody gives a [ __ ] which is nice
you know but back then that would like
ruin your whole [ __ ] life right
pretty
much some of them are still around it's
just that that's the only thing you
could do that's yeah you couldn't go
straight i mean tracy lords is the only
one that did movies that actually went
she got kicked out of porn for being
underage yeah yeah so yeah she had a
different situation but she actually
went on to
be in like quote unquote real movies
yeah she was in blade
she looked good she looked great too she
married just a regular guy bartender
who didn't and she didn't he didn't know
she who she was
that's great that's cool though didn't
know who she was until later i just saw
her and well the a movie i reviewed last
week um excision which i think came out
in 2012 or 2014 or something like that
she was in that too yeah john waters was
in it too yeah cause she was in a lot of
those john waters movies like she was
cute she was in crybaby yeah man that's
another one i want to see again that
john waters maybe crybaby do you ever
see that no yeah tracy lords is in it
johnny depp is in it like when he was
really young
it's good
man i love john waters but uh yeah
she hosted world's scariest places
huh
what do you know all right so we've been
going like almost an hour yeah it's time
to shut down that's all we can say about
i recommend the movie
it's worth 3.99 you can rent it on
amazon amazon prime that's where we got
it yeah yeah if you don't have that you
can probably yeah i think it's also on
youtube you can rent it on youtube yeah
you can um but no
fun movie it's up there with like yeah
if you like weird 70s [ __ ] it's totally
worth watching yeah it's insane yeah and
it's not crazy it's insane but it makes
sense yeah it makes sense it makes it's
uh it's logical a lot of good ideas in
it
it's just uh it was ahead of his time it
was over ambitious yeah that's all yeah
um so yeah so we'll be back tomorrow
either talking about orca or if we watch
exorcist two we'll maybe talk about that
so it'll be one of those two movies
probably uh so yeah thanks everybody for
dropping by thanks for super chats and
we will see you guys again tomorrow
afternoon